Oh wait, wrong one one.
Sorry.
Sorry, wrong screen.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
I hope you guys had a nice rest day yesterday.
I sure did.
I slept so much.
Oh my gosh, I slept a lot.
Oh my god, look at all of you guys.
believe it's been one month of memberships already that's
actually crazy that's a really i've been like streaming for
a month now oh my god congratulations um i have no other
badges other than tomatoes so and we won't be having other
badges yet okay the reason why is that um i'm trying to like
finalize some stuff right now regarding like my new skin
suit so like is why we don't have a badge after the tomato
because I'm trying to like figure out what I want to do uh
what I want to do for my badges at the moment most likely
will be dragoon themed as always but then like I'm like
trying to figure out for uh like after because like you know
we you know after the dragoon badges like what's after that
so so that's why that's why um there's no there's in a
tomato badge for now like we're trying to do everything i'm
wondering so many things i have to do anyway um i love how
like this game has like a rage quit option too that that
makes sense that makes sense for the type of game that we're
playing today for those who are wondering wow dokey what
game are you playing today it's called a difficult game
about climbing it's not by the creators of getting over it
um it is like a spiritual success to getting over it by some
different person instead of you know a pot and a
sledgehammer we're gonna be rock climbing and like okay I
usually never touch these types of games but I also had a
perfectly good excuse to not touch these types of games one
of them was that like I could be like oh I don't know guys
perm issue but now I don't really have that anymore FOMO,
the fear of missing out.
You know, because, like, it just came out, and everybody is
playing it now.
All the streamers are playing it.
So, like, no!
Now I have FOMO!
I can't use the excuse anymore!
Because then I could be like, well, guys, the game came out
a long time ago.
And, like, I don't want to put myself through that.
I don't want to put myself through that, because I know it's
a really, it's a rage game.
It's a game that's making you're supposed to be raging the
game just came out
This game this game is just came out.
So now I don't have any excuse because it's the streamer
game now And now I'm feeling the FOMO.
I'm feeling it guys.
I'm feeling the fear of missing out I don't have any excuses
anymore.
I'm weak to FOMO
It's the meta stream game I need to follow the meta.
I'm always following the meta No I'm really feeling the FOMO
at the moment.
I'm feeling it.
Okay, also like we're gonna have some background music
because like this this game is like it's like water You you
hear you hear water.
So let me just let me put like a BGM just to be a little
sane I don't know if you guys can hear that.
That might be a bit too quiet.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, so the goal is to climb.
Okay, I don't know if the game is too loud.
Let me check.
Alright, okay, and then we do this.
And then, how do I?
And then I grab, like, oh, wait, this is so easy!
What's so difficult about climbing?
I don't understand.
What can be so difficult about this?
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I can feel.
Wait, now, wait, sorry.
I think I know now.
I think.
Okay, wait.
Wait, I think.
No, no, I don't!
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I think I understand now.
I think I understand what could be so difficult about a
difficult game about climbing.
What?
What's your weak ass hand doing?
Is it?
Oh, it's because this water is... This is a shaky rock.
Because it's like water.
Oh, guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning.
It's a shaky rock.
Okay, now this is the easiest fucking game I've ever played.
Okay.
Can I grab...
Can I grab can?
I can.
Okay.
I mean, the controls are very intuitive.
Like, it's not...
I swear to God.
Can I grab the side?
Yeah, okay.
Alright.
It's not, you know, it's not that stupid.
Okay, I need to remember what you...
What?
No!
I can't just swim away.
I can't believe it.
Okay, now I know.
Now I can feel it.
No!
guys now i understand i understand now i don't understand
why couldn't you climb okay all right at least like i died
there you know it's not that bad all right here you go up
and then climb there you go I got this down I mean this is
honestly the controls for this it's I'll say it it's easier
than getting over it is 100% easier than getting over it
it's like so intuitive like even a fucking child can do this
now I need to figure out how to get over it okay come on use
your upper body strength come on come on Yes!
Your arm can go further!
Yes, okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
He stretched himself.
Alright, and then we're gonna climb this fucking bark.
Okay.
That's good.
Alright, where the fuck do I go from there?
I don't know.
Okay, we're gonna grab...
We're gonna...
Please.
Okay, this... I hate this BG.
I might have chose like the fucking worst BGM ever Okay,
please There we go There we go, we're fine, we're fine Okay
Where do I fuck do I go?
Where do I go?
Okay Oh no No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
I don't understand Why can't he use his legs Is he stupid?
Like...
I don't understand!
Why do I lose my grip there and not the other way around?
I need...
The sense needs to be higher.
I can't.
Is he fucking stupid?
Why can't he fucking grip that?
Okay.
Alright.
I can speedrun this part.
No!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Alright.
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine please please just
grip it just grip it i don't understand why you're weak to
water okay it's okay we're good we can speed run this part
like this part is easy oh don't go too fast don't go too
fast go okay nice i'm speed running this part okay yes okay
all right we're good we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good okay okay okay what do we do here though
what what do we do here though what do we do here though i
don't know do i do i oh oh oh okay i grip that and i grip
the box
Yes.
All right.
You can go higher.
Higher than you ever gone before, Mr. Man.
Okay.
All right.
I'm up!
You know, this game is pretty easy, actually.
Okay.
If I just keep...
Oh, I can grip bushes!
Wait, that's new information!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just keep gripping the bushes.
Yes.
And up I go!
Yes!
Up you go!
Oh, sir!
Nice!
Wait, what?
What do I do?
Wait.
What do I do from here?
Down?
What?
I don't want to go down.
I worked so hard to get here!
What do I...
No!
Don't make me go down!
The leap of faith.
Okay, here we go.
Oh!
No!
Why did I listen?
Why did I listen to you guys?
Oh, so it's a BGM too loud or is it good?
No.
Why did I go down?
It was too much pain.
Too, not that down.
The other down.
Oh, shit.
It's too quiet?
Okay.
I didn't realize it was too quiet.
I've been listening to the sound.
This BGM, like, blasted up to my ears.
Do you guys hear that?
Okay, I'll turn it up a little.
Oh, now.
Alright.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Like, I'm sorry I'm getting better at this.
Alright.
No!
It's fine.
we're fine this is a game for babies it's not that difficult
i would say this is easier than getting over it 100 so you
look at me i can like speed run this let me maybe i should
watch a speed run shout out the highest working link cop
every uh pass the boy thank you with a super chat thank you
thank you okay if i like do this and then yes okay okay you
just keep climbing You won't let this...
Okay, nice.
Bush.
Good job, Bush.
Okay.
Come on.
You got this.
Come on, sir.
No!
Don't let water destroy you!
It's just water!
Oh, oh, okay.
All right.
It's okay.
Climbing!
Just keep climbing!
Scratch and break your nails!
Okay.
All right.
We're fine.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Then...
Okay.
Nope.
We're gonna... Use that to boost our momentum and go...
Wait.
What the fuck?
How did you lose your grip?
There we go.
Nice.
I figured it out.
I figured out the system.
And then we grab this.
Oh, God.
This is scary.
No.
No, no, no, no!
Ah!
Why?
I'm gonna need to get out of a controller.
I need...
Okay, up, higher.
The sensitivity must be higher!
Okay.
Honestly, I think it's like you max out the senses the way
to go, honestly, at this point.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
We got this one down.
Alright.
And then...
I don't understand why my grip will sometimes get fucked.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
And then we just keep...
Boost!
Alright.
And then we grab this.
And then... Okay.
Okay.
Boost!
Nice.
Okay, okay.
Here you go.
This is the way.
Boost!
Sir!
Pull up!
pull up okay okay here we try again pull up there you go I'm
like honestly there might be a time where I pull out the
controller I feel like a controller might be easier to
handle all right here you go okay I want grab the other hand
oh all Alright, nice.
Okay.
I didn't grab the tree branch there.
Alright, here we go.
Boop.
Bush.
Okay.
No, no, no.
That's not a bush.
Okay, we need to grab.
We need to grab the grass.
Grab the grass, sir.
Okay.
Here we go.
And we need to grab a higher upper of the grass.
Okay, one, two, three!
Yes!
Good job!
Alright!
This part, I don't know.
I don't know.
Do I just swing?
Woo!
Okay, I swing.
Okay.
Okay, that was scary.
That was a little scary.
There's bones now, too.
All right, what do I do here?
Do I...
Do I swing?
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
Do I...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's a bad idea.
Don't get me that.
a bad idea i don't i don't know i'm so scared oh no bone
knock bone knock
okay do i go down do i no go up i where where go where do i
climb okay bone knock it's true i hate fomo
see this!
This is your time to shine!
No!
Do I swing?
Damn you, FOMO!
But the bone zone.
Damn you, FOMO.
Why are ranged game streamer games?
God damn it.
I wish I was a game programmer.
So I can make rage games Hey guys, thank you for the
Hakasupa Thank you, thank you Nice demonstration, I can see
your skill And how you got this game Figured out, ex-expect,
yeah Yeah, I figured it out Yeah Yeah Figured it out Thank
you for the Hakasupa Thank you, thank you Okay Alright, here
we go Nice, alright Oh yeah, I forgot how's the sound by the
way I forgot to ask you guys how you think about the sound
if it's too loud or it's perfect At least I got this part
down like this part is fucking easy This part is for fucking
babies Which is soft the game sound or okay Do you really
need to know about like do you really need to know the game
sound of this man All he's doing oh my god all he's doing is
just grunting like in the water like that's all he's doing
he's just grunting so you guys don't you're not missing out
you're not missing out right now don't worry there's no foam
modes that he had here okay here you go the grunting is
important don't understand okay we need to hear this man
It's important!
Okay, okay, here you go.
Here you go.
There, I'll voice active for you guys.
It might just be the same.
Here.
Please, please grab onto this.
Okay.
Come on.
Boost yourself up.
Boost!
Okay, nice.
All right, we got the boost.
Okay, we know we need to pick this up.
And then...
Okay.
One, two, three!
There we go.
Nice.
And then...
Yes.
Okay.
I need to grab...
I need to grab the side.
No, it's not what I want.
Okay, one.
One, two, three!
Nice.
We got it.
Okay, we got this down.
This part is super easy.
This part is, like, really easy for me.
The scariest part is the dropping down.
Because, like, I don't have faith in anything.
Okay.
One, two, three!
Nice.
Alright, we gotta fall now.
I don't wanna fall.
I don't.
One, two, three!
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
Don't worry.
What is... I hate... This sucks.
Okay.
Here we go.
Where do I go from here?
I don't understand.
Where do I...
Do I swing?
There's no way.
There's no way I can make it.
Do I make it?
No.
Full swing?
Okay.
What?
Okay, I'm scared.
Guys, guys, I'm scared.
I am so scared.
The sign?
What sign?
Okay.
Full swing?
What if we don't make it?
Higher up?
Here?
We go?
Higher?
But like, that's where I came from.
What do you mean?
Aim for the...
the side but how okay go high and then okay no you're too
far guys I'm scared I'm scared okay one oh god oh god this
is where it gets difficult we're already down okay one two
for the sign.
Okay.
I just need to grab the bone.
Alright.
Grab the bone.
Okay.
What's the world record currently?
What even is the current world record for this game?
Like, well.
Okay.
Seven fucking minutes?
Bro!
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Toki?
Okay.
Alright, here you go.
Well, at least, like, I'm, like, feeling...
Feeling this game now.
I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling this game now.
I don't even need to do it a boost.
I can just, like...
I can just do it in regular bounces.
Okay.
Now I need to do it a boost, though.
Alright.
Here you go.
Up I go.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
dokey whoa whoa whoa okay let me do this arm okay no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no okay one two three no
don't fall don't fall don't fall okay oh don't fall okay we
got this part down we just yeah we just need to start we
just need to where's your other no no no no no no no No, no,
no, no.
Where's your other guard?
I'm going.
Where is it going?
All right, nice.
No!
Why did the bush fail me?
Why is the bush failing me?
I fucking hate the water!
Okay, I'm good.
I'm okay.
I need to turn down the BGM.
The VGN's pissing me off.
Why are you so stupid?
Use your fucking legs.
I don't understand.
Okay.
It's only been 26 minutes.
I swear.
I feel like I've been playing this game for an hour already.
I hate FOMO.
Okay.
I swear.
It feels like I've been playing for like hours.
I feel like I've just like witnessed everything in life.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright, nice.
We grab that.
And then we grab this.
And then okay.
Okay, then.
Swing!
There we go.
Alright.
Swing!
There we go.
If you yell swing, you're gonna hit it.
Here we go.
One.
Two.
three okay all right okay one two three nice we grab that
like this part is like super easy now but like oh my god as
i get higher and higher holy shit by the way guys i was like
talking to the minecraft team the people who are for those
who are going to be members you guys don't know we're going
to be creating a members uh minecraft community server i was
i was talking to like about like faction making factions and
stuff so like basically okay wait give me a sec guys sorry
you're gonna be on a cliffhanger because i need to get to
the other fucking side give me a sec swing okay okay okay
anyway as i was saying so he's thank you for the macheta
super thank you thank you doki's a pro climber ex-expected
thank you all right so like the most exciting part is that
we're talking about how to do the faction stuff and like
basically like oh oh oh okay so Sorry, I had to...
Okay, basically, it's going to be...
When you enter the town, when you enter the lobby, the
pre-made town, you get to pick your faction.
So, like, obviously the faction is going to be divided by,
like, Long Goon, Chonky Goon, Egg Goon, and, like, regular
Goon.
And, like, and then, like, there's going to be, like, power
levels.
And, like, the stronger your faction is, the more land you
can claim.
be like you can like wage wars against other dragon for more
land and and like and like there's gonna be like a communal
bank system or something and so like the more the more
dragon types you kill like the more enemy dragoons you kill
the more lad you can claim so i was like talking to like the
minecraft team about that
so all right here you go let's see i'm gonna figure out how
to swing which which is the best area to swing from like do
i go higher or i'm getting um all right well do i do i go
higher do i the bone okay the bonus yeah the bonus slippery
what do you mean okay uh bone bad bone bad everything
changed with the nesticle faction attack those are thank you
for the super champ thank you thank you okay closer to the
side let me know do hot and cold am i hot sorry am i am i
close to the thing am i am i Cold or hot to the to the area
Okay, a bit higher area a bit higher here.
Is that it?
Am I at the swing the optimal swing?
Guys, okay, I need no amount.
This is important guys.
Am I at the optimal swing?
A bit higher here
Here God oh God no where too high okay here here is this it
is this the optimal swing is this the optimal swing cold
cold or hot I'm not gonna wing it lower okay okay here Okay,
is this optimal swing?
Is this optimal swing?
I swear to God, I will pull up the fucking speedrun of this
just to figure out which is the optimal swing.
Okay.
What?
No!
I'm fucking pulling up the vote.
Give me a second
Difficult game about climbing speed run.
I'm pulling up.
I'm fucking all right 7.55.
What the fuck it goes to us?
Why is he purple?
Okay What the fuck guys?
Okay, I blame you guys This could have been so much easier
Like, guys, I can't believe you made this harder than I
expected.
I can't believe it.
Alright, I should have just...
I should have just fucking watched a professional.
I see.
Yeah, why is he...
Phanab?
Alright, here you go.
I can't believe it, guys.
My Oshim MatPat graduated, like...
Was it yesterday?
I don't even remember.
Guys, he's my Oshim, but I don't even remember.
I can't believe it.
The biggest graduation stream I've ever seen.
All right, here you go.
Sad.
I can't believe it.
I like how he made, I watched a little bit because I was
curious, like, what his last video was going to be.
And then, like, I love how, like, he, like, announced a
website and it literally crashed in one second.
Like, I thought I was like, I was like, is this a virus?
Because I was like, What is this website?
And then, like, what the fuck?
It literally crashed the moment it was posted.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
This is fine.
This part I got, hands down.
Oh.
Except for that part.
This part I got, like, easily.
Alright.
07 to our Oshi map, Pat.
Now, who am I going to go to?
all the wacky FNAF theories.
It's funny, though, to see him, like, call out Scott for,
like, stealing his theories.
But Scott literally made him.
The creator of FNAF.
Like, his... Like, yeah, his videos were popular, but, like,
FNAF made him for who he is.
Okay.
Let's see.
Here we go.
Woo!
What the fuck?
Okay.
That is, like, so scary, though.
Every time.
Every time I'm doing that leap of fate.
Okay, it's, like, here.
This is the spot, the optimal swing spot.
And then you go like this.
Who?
Okay, wait.
Wait, and then...
Oh, my God.
This is so scary.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need to add the last...
He is.
Give me a sec.
How does he do it?
How does this man do it?
Okay, he grabs...
Oh my god, that's so scary!
How does he do that?
Okay, am I at that right spot?
Is it higher?
It's higher, okay.
Okay.
Okay, it's like here.
This is how he does it.
This is so scary.
I have to believe.
What?
It doesn't matter if I'm cheating!
I can't even get it right!
Okay, wait, wait, but I can't even get that shit right!
What does it matter?
But what I did learn.
What I did learn.
How does he do it?
Please.
This would save so much time.
Please, purple guy.
No.
Okay, this would save so much time, though.
Just think about it.
Please.
This would save so much time.
I know you can do this.
Oh, no, you can do it.
I...
Fuck, I give up.
Well, we're fucking...
We're not meant to speedrun.
We were never meant to speedrun, guys.
We were...
We were not meant to speedrun.
We were just a streamer.
Okay.
Look, I speedrun real games.
Like, Peppa Pig.
Not fucking difficult game about climbing.
You won't see this in SDGT, cutie.
Okay.
Ugh.
Please.
No, I'm losing it.
I'm losing it.
I'm losing my touch.
No, no, no.
You're not losing it, Doki.
You gotta believe.
Come on.
This is so easy for you.
Okay.
Oh, no.
This is not the right angle.
Okay, one, two, three!
There you go.
Oh, I mean, the controls aren't bad.
The controls aren't bad.
It's a fun game.
Oh, no, please, please, please, please.
Grab some sand.
Okay.
Come on, up you go.
All right.
Oh, God.
Okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
And we have to swing from here.
Okay.
I got the swing for this down.
Ah!
Yeah.
Okay.
Like, I got the leap of faith for this down.
But how do you do this?
Like...
Oh!
What arm is this?
Okay, that's this arm.
Okay.
Can I climb this?
Why can't I climb this?
Give me.
If I...
Give me...
Why can't I climb this?
I don't...
Oh, God.
Oh, oh, please.
Oh, please.
Climbing guy.
Sir.
Please.
Think of the children.
Oh, no.
I don't like...
this I don't like this oh god oh god I'm so stressed out I'm
so stressed out swing okay okay no no no
Okay.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
I'm gonna fall.
I can feel it.
I can feel the fall.
Please!
Let me touch you!
Oh, she falls.
She falls.
Please!
Ah!
That, let's say that,
it was there, it was in my grass, I can't fail, didn't I, I
fell, I'm looking up the speed right, there is a way to get
there faster, I need a no, I don't, I don't want it, okay,
teach me purple, guy, teach me purple, what the fuck am I
watching, okay, okay, Purple guy.
Purple guy, teach me.
That's fucking right.
I can do this.
Go purple guy, go.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, give me a sec.
I still need to figure this out, though.
I figured it out, guys.
Purple guy taught me.
Watch this.
Do you guys want to see something cool?
Okay, not yet.
I cut my time!
So, guys, I pioneered that.
I just made up that trick today.
Guys, isn't that cool?
Guys, I made up that trick, guys.
Oh, my God.
Please.
It's not plagiarized.
It's called the Doki Grasp.
Trademarked by Doki.
I discovered it today.
Guys.
Damn.
Not a trade.
I trademarked it.
Guys, call me...
Who is it?
Who's the guy who steals all?
I mean, who, like, invents everything.
Thomas Edison.
Wait, no.
What is it?
Guys, Tesla, who?
Okay, here you go.
Okay, wait.
Wait, we got this.
All right.
He was a genius, Thomas Edison, inventing all these
inventions.
That's right.
role model right there guys what a fuck is Tesla all I know
about Tesla is that it's a car that's his only contribution
to society he tried to fucking frame my Oshi Thomas Edison
for stealing ideas I'm fucking he's the loser who didn't
trademark Let's see.
Ah!
No!
Yeah.
Got it.
Well, I don't want to grow up.
I want me just like Mr. Edison inventing all those cool
ideas.
Just like, I'm getting there.
I invented the dokey grasp.
Oh my god, speedrunners are going to use.
Okay, anytime you see a speedrunner that used my passionate
dokey grasp, just remember I did that.
I...
I pioneered the dokey grass.
Watch this.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, wait, wait.
Sorry.
Okay, so for those who would like to learn speedrunning,
what you do is that you put your hand right here, and then
you go down, and then you go up.
And then, sorry, this is not what you shouldn't do.
This is what you shouldn't do.
this is what you should do is like this okay so what you
should do is like this okay guys give me a sec guys give me
a sec guys guys don't worry I'm trying to I'm teaching you
what the wrong ways are what oh god please please there you
go Please, the donkey grasp, please!
Padded it by donkey bird!
Okay.
Donkey grasp.
Donkey just grasp it.
Donkey grasp!
I don't understand why is this so much harder now.
I don't understand.
I was doing so well.
I was doing so well with the donkey grasp.
Yeah, sorry.
There's like so many people that have been doing the grass
prong and I'm trying to show you all the wrong ways to do it
Before I do the right way Come on.
Come on.
No, you can you out.
You're strong enough for this.
Come on Come on Come on.
No I see how it's saved it does it saves so much time.
Look at me go That's like you're right by pure spite and
anger.
Fuck you ever said that i did it for you okay oh my god i
don't know why i did that i don't know why that was way too
risky okay okay no please why is it so difficult to grasp it
i don't understand how does he
How do you do that?
How do you do all of this?
Like, oh my god.
The toky drop.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't drop.
Every time I fall, it's like strategic, guys.
I just felt like I reset my timer, guys.
I reset my timer every time I drop.
Because I feel like it's just not...
It's just not an optimal time.
As a fellow speedrunner, you would understand, but you're
not.
You don't understand because you're not part of the group.
Look at that.
Fuck, okay.
Guys, I just wanted to do it again, guys.
I was like, I was like, that was way too easy that I knew,
like, people didn't see it, so I had to do it again.
Guys, I was like, oh my God, that was way too fucking easy
how I grasped that.
everybody that missed out.
Okay.
Please.
Okay, wait.
There you go.
All right, there you go.
Yeah, you guys saw that?
All right, good, because I'm not doing it again.
I felt like I was giving you guys too many examples on how
to do it.
gotta learn eventually okay okay that was a little risky
that was a little too risky for me okay no i didn't let go
it's hard why why is the doki swing guys i just haven't
perfected the doki swing i just haven't perfected the doki
swing guys we will we will see more than just the rock
there's a town nearby apparently there's a town i want to
see the town let me see the town please that's all i ask i
just want to see the town please let me see the town please
let me see the town okay all right that's all i want that's
all i'll do Doki wants.
She wants to know what the city looks like.
Okay.
We're almost there, guys.
I will perfect the Doki swing.
Okay.
What the fuck?
How did I do it?
I don't understand.
How the fuck did I do it?
Needs work, but the donkey drop is on point.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
How did I do it?
How?
Okay.
It was just so perfect that I can't perfect it.
There we go.
All right.
We're good.
We're just gonna keep climbing.
keep climbing keep climbing you will get the jokie swing
give me a second you look at a professional time out time
out it's like basketball where you get your coach in guys
don't worry i have a coach
don't worry i have a coach how the fuck does he do that is
it because he has a top hat
Is it the top hat?
Is it the fucking top hat?
How do I get the top hat?
Okay, I need to make sure I don't fall.
What arm is this?
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, here you go.
It must be the hat.
I think it's the hat.
I think it's the fucking hat.
There's...
Oh, oh, God.
I do that timeout.
That timeout worked, guys.
The timeout!
Oh, God.
Oh!
No!
Use a foot.
Guys!
If I could use a foot, I would use a foot!
Okay.
Here you go.
Oh, yeah, it's okay.
It's okay.
It gives me more chance to perfect all my techniques.
Guys, it's like that...
It's like that...
That Kung Fu movie where, like, Like, you do, like,
meaningless task.
You think, like, they're meaningless tasks.
But, like, all these techniques that we're learning now.
Like, the...
Like, the Doki...
The Doki...
Grasp.
It's gonna help us in the long run, guys.
Guys, like, that shit?
Look at that.
I figured out the shortcut, too.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, Karate Kid.
We're just Karate Kidding it right now.
The Doki Grasp.
It's gonna save lives.
You don't understand.
We're just slowly perfecting the dokey grasp.
And then it'll be like baby mode.
I'm just gonna put them...
You'll see.
You'll see, you guys.
The moment I let go of my training weights.
You'll see.
Okay, here you go.
Please.
Okay, okay, here you go.
Oh, God, please, please, please.
Please.
Just firmly grasp it.
We perfected you.
What happened?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I told you we perfected it.
I knew we perfected this.
Look at that.
Look at how fast we cut time!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
The dokey swing.
Here it comes.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my god!
We're doing it!
Okay, okay, time out.
Basketball time out.
Basketball time out!
How does he do it?
How do you do that swing?
Okay, he was like, whoa!
Okay, okay, basketball time out.
Don't worry, we're back in.
Benny, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank
you.
I can finally watch stream again.
I get free.
I'm free.
Welcome back, Betty.
Oh, God.
Okay, grasp.
Okay.
He grasped this.
Coach said, guys, Coach said, I need to put my hand right
here and then do a swing.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
And then what?
No, no, no, no.
Coach, coach, coach, coach!
Coach!
okay and then and then a swing okay coach coach i need help
coach coach i need help
please coach how do you do this okay and then oh my god
please please please don't no
my god why is that part so difficult i just want to see the
town let me see the town i don't want to finish this game i
just want to see the city that's all that's all i want i
don't even care i never want to finish this game Lily, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Each atom that stone.
Each mineral flake of that night filled mountain.
An item forms a world.
The struggle itself to towards the height is enough to fill
a bird's heart.
One must imagine Tokyo is happy.
I'm so happy.
Guys, there's a city!
A saw city!
The coach saw a city!
It exists.
It's like the fountain of youth.
It exists, guys.
I'll be the Spaniards who discovered the city.
Love you.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Doki, for showing me how to master the Doki dive.
Now I feel like a true speedrun.
No!
This won't be my legacy!
Oh my god, the Doki swing.
The Doki swing is getting better and better.
I refuse to let that be my legacy Oh god Please Please Come
on man Come on Man come on Just grasp it
There's the civilization Shit.
See, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I just want to see the city.
Please.
I just want to know what the city looks like.
They must have fiber over there.
Oh god.
At least like that part is getting easier.
Of course it's easy.
I fucking trademarked that.
Of course.
Joki, what are you trying to say?
Of course it'll be easy.
You literally trademarked this...
God damn it, swing.
Nice and thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, I'll be like the back roll banner.
Oh!
I'll go check it out later.
You're right.
Don't worry.
But first, Doki must grasp.
And Doki must swing.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Please, please stop worrying.
Guys, please stop worrying.
Doki's got this.
God, please.
Guys, why are you worried?
Why are you worried, guys?
Doki's got this!
Doki, what happened?
You were a master?
There you go.
Good job.
God, why are you so fucking good at video games?
Okay.
No!
Stop!
Why are
you...
I can't believe it, please!
Patches, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's really cool that they break up this swimming game with
a bit of rock climbing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I swear, I'm pretty sure more than 50% of a game is me
climbing.
You can't say that.
How dare you this is the stream where the where I've
discovered the speed run the speed run technique How dare
you please.
Oh, God.
Okay.
All right.
We got this down.
How dare you.
This is a master at work right now This is literally a
master at work.
Oh God, please, please.
Oh my God, please
Doki Swing!
Oh, God.
I almost fell off.
I let go.
I was so excited.
I actually let go.
I knew it.
I knew the Doki Swing was right!
Okay.
Oh.
The Doki Swing.
The Doki Swing will always prevail.
There were so many doubters.
So many people that didn't believe in me.
That's right.
You're all Teslas.
You'll never be like Thomas Edison.
My Oshi.
You'll never be as great as my Oshi.
You're all Teslas.
What a wild statement.
There you go.
How dare you say Edison suck.
Edison invented everything there's the money after this
stream okay where do i go from here where the fuck do i go i
don't want to go in the water what if i die i don't know if
i can is this a checkpoint guys this is important is this a
checkpoint do i draw yes oh thank god oh thank god okay oh i
didn't get one guy i was worried to get that i'd get one
guide i was so fucking worried all right here you go
congratulations you finally finished the tutorial now good
luck thank you for this chat thank you thank you god i'm
scared here actually oh god okay grasp the bush grasp the
bush okay here you go i made it guys i made it to the first
checkpoint wait do i grasp this yeah i think so okay all
right this is good this is good and then please okay we're
not gonna we're not gonna go down what would Edison do
always tell yourself what would Thomas Edison do your words
of motivation is right here oh oh oh oh oh god oh god oh god
oh god where's my other hand where's my other hand where is
it Edison would not fall fall yes it would not fall yes it
would never give up and we'll keep on stealing ideas I mean
um he is a great inventor guys like why climbing and
swimming game thank you for the super chat these thank you
thank you channel Edison all right here yeah this is it all
right here yeah He would never fall!
All right All right, here you go.
Okay, okay here you go.
Gotta get a bit closer Got a bit closer that bush before we
can grow Here you go.
All right, this is it All right, we gotta Yeah Grass, the
bush!
Okay, the bush has been grasped.
Alright.
I am so scared.
Oh, God.
I don't like this level.
I don't like this level at all.
There's too much water.
I hate water.
Why must we need water to survive?
What has water...
You know what?
I wish the human body never needed water.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, and then.
Come on.
There is a rock right here!
Okay, nice.
What has water done for me?
Nothing!
Okay, this way.
Why must we need water?
It's stupid!
Oh, God.
That is like...
Such a fucking scary bush right there.
This way.
Down we go.
Is that bush I can grab?
I can't tell.
I can't tell what I can grab and what I can't grab.
No, that's just rock.
Wait, what?
What do I grab?
Down here?
Okay.
Come on.
Your arm can extend higher Don't fuck with me
Okay, I know your hand can extend higher than this Okay,
that's a scary, that's a scary rock there Alright I can't,
I'm trying I'm trying to grab Okay Alright
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that was close.
That was a little too close.
I didn't like that.
Guys, I might have to call a timeout.
My coach might want me to call a timeout, guys.
I...
Okay, here we go.
All right.
Up.
Up, Baco.
No, no, no.
Oh, sanctuary!
Sanctuary!
It started thinking with a super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I might have to call it basketball timeout, guys.
Okay, thank you.
No coach only club.
Do you think Michael Phelps didn't do it all by himself?
Michael Phelps.
I don't know if you guys know other than his fucking
proportionally abnormal fucking body.
Because his fucking arms are longer than, like, the fucking
rest of his body.
He needed a coach, too, guys.
It's not just genetics.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
All right, this is it.
This is it.
All right, we grass the bush.
We grass the branch right here.
There we go.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, it's not just genetics.
We have to remember the coaches we have all alive!
You think Thomas Edison did this all by himself?
He did.
He's a fucking genius, and that's why he's my O-Sheet.
Don't believe the lies, Tesla says.
The only man that's never needed a coach was thomas edison
all him okay there you go all right that's why he's maloshi
okay this is an anti tesla zone i'm a tesla auntie that's
looking right i will die a tesla auntie He didn't steal jack
shit!
That's what the haters said!
You don't have proof!
It's been hundreds of years!
Move on!
Okay, hey!
Alright, here we go!
Oh my god, please, let me...
Let me go around!
Okay, please!
Okay, grass, okay!
No!
Okay, I'll take out.
Okay.
Let's...
Tesla's landing.
Matt, I love President Thomas Edison.
It's an addition.
Guys, move on!
Edison won!
Move on, Tesla fans!
Okay, this is it.
Ugh!
I don't know what to do.
I don't remember how I did this what is this game it is a
game that reunites it's helped to inflame my love for my
Oshi Tesla Shillows and Shambos oh shit I hate this I hate
that all right here we go
All right, here you go.
All right.
Let's see what down we...
I don't know how to do this.
Yes!
Guys, I'm calling in my coach, Thomas Edison.
Yes, I'm calling in my coach.
How does he do it?
Coach, coach, I'm struggling.
How do you do that, coach?
It's okay.
Coach will save me.
Oh, okay.
He did that.
Okay.
Coach is there.
Coach, Coach Edison!
Thank you, Coach Edison.
With your power, I shall be able to climb now.
No.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Coach!
Coach!
Thank you, Coach!
Oh, Coach!
Coach, I'm falling!
Is this supposed to?
happen okay all right i figured out though i figured out how
to get through that coach said that was supposed to happen
because i didn't do it good enough he said that coach edison
told me that because i didn't do the technique properly
enough that i have to restart from down there don't worry
coach i'll perfect this technique Yes, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Pulling up the Ouija board every time.
Every time I'm just contact their Ochi.
You don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
I need to climb up the rock.
Oh god.
Here you go.
Coach!
I swear, Coach!
Let me have another chance!
I got this, Coach!
Coach!
Please don't make me restart!
Okay.
Alright, we gotta get up from here.
There you go.
I figured it.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Okay, we need two hands on this rock.
And then Okay, here you go Here you go And then No!
Okay, it's fine, we had drop here It's our sanctuary We
could drop here Alright, go try it, thank you Super Chat,
thank you, thank you I just got here, thank you for Starting
at the beginning for me This isn't the beginning This is the
sanctuary Thank you for this Super Chat, thank you Thank
you.
Here you go.
Alright.
This is fine.
Okay.
We're good.
Oh, we made it though.
We made it here.
This is fine.
Come on.
Just grasp it.
The donkey grasp.
the donkey grasp okay maybe the donkey grasp back here uh
let's see okay all right come on come on no no come on
please please i just want to see the city i want to know
what the city looks like i've only heard stories from maoshi
Please!
I remember when I first saw Maoshi, Mr. Thomas Edison.
He promised me a tale.
He promised me a golden city.
If I've reached the top!
Please!
Okay.
It's okay.
it's okay we're fine go ahead thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you please just please please let me grab it
why can't i grab water why are you a liquid are you stupid
okay all right i'm good i'm good i'm good i just need to
grab this rock I can't even grab rocks anymore.
I can't even, okay, here we go.
It says DC electricity has been reduced to batteries.
Tesla's AC electricity is used to power up homes and
appliances today.
Checkmate.
That's a lie.
That's a lie that Tesla wants you to believe.
Those were paid for by Tesla shares.
Open your mind.
Tesla paid for all that.
You're getting shielded by the Tesla core.
Nice try, Tesla propagandist.
You can't fool me.
Edison already told me to be careful with people like you.
Okay.
Here we go.
Please, I cannot grab that rocket.
Don't be a sheep.
Open your eyes.
Oh, thank God.
It just hit my head on the rocket.
It's okay.
I'm still here.
Get off Twitter.
Get off Twitter and read a book.
Tesla share.
Read the history books.
No one talks about Tesla there.
They say history books are written by winners.
That means it's true.
That means Thomas Edison won.
So it's true.
Here you go.
Edison lives in Doki's head.
That's so true.
That's right!
That means Tesla's a loser!
If he's not in that history, books!
Alright, let's go.
I didn't expect myself to start my day ranting about this.
It is an impenetra- Exactly!
Taurus, thank you for listening to the chat, thank you,
thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
That's- here we go.
Make a bullet!
Vincent versus Tesla.
I don't need to make a poll.
I know who's a real winner.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
You know, now that I think about it, eventually somebody's
gonna draw like Bishiman.
Is that how you pronounce it?
Bishiman, Tesla, and Edison.
Unless somebody were gonna draw like, someone's gonna draw
like a manga but like Tesla and Edison or something like
reincarnated Tesla and Edison in like modern world and then
people are going to ship this to I swear if it hasn't been
done already I know it's going to happen manga manga anime
has no balance it will always happen eventually it already
exists yeah it came then tesla and edison i can feel it to
edison is the jock and then
and tesla's the art kid the worlds collide
don't you stop here you go if it hasn't happened yet it's
going to you guys know it don't stop it available.
You can't stop it.
Okay.
Here you go.
Please, let me grasp the rock.
Oh, God.
Oh, right.
And then, okay, here you go.
And then, like, Edison and Tesla got a sign on a science
project together.
And then Tesla thought that, like, Edison and him were
getting closer but then like he felt betrayed because thomas
edison took all the credit for his work and then never
talked to him again after the science project and then he
was heartbroken stop
oh they got a sanctuary so i'm letting her cook all right
here we go all right i can't believe they'll get got
cancelled over 200 year old corporate espionage thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you general never cook
again it exists i don't even need a cook i'm pretty sure it
exists somewhere i'm pretty sure you can't stop you can't
stop it all right here you go oh there you go nice we got
the bush it's the rock i can never do the rock anymore.
I can never do that rock!
Please!
Please for Edison!
Ah, please.
Please, I'm just...
Please, my coach is watching me.
He's filming this, please.
Please, I don't want to be kicked out of the Edison Club.
I worked so hard!
There you go.
Oh, thank God.
No!
You're right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And it's a new telegram.
Who's this Tesla fiercely typing?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Dira, thank you for the super chat.
Okay, wait, wait.
Wait, before I...
No!
because of the Hamilton musical.
I've ironically seen people shift historical figures of
those guys are based off.
So Tesla X Edison is definitely a thing that probably
exists.
Anything is shippable.
You can't avoid it.
Kitchen appliances can't be shippable.
Are you thinking hard enough?
But please don't think hard enough.
guys we don't need all right okay here go all right dokey
please stop cooking i'm not reckoning for nicola to ship
this sale thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's too late it's too late i'm pretty sure it already
exists i'm pretty sure we just need to make them anime boys
We need to make them anime boys or girls, you know, because
that also works, too.
If we can do it with countries, we can do it with Tesla and
Addison.
Not just once, but three times.
Do you think it only happened in Italia?
Notification of countries three fucking times and they are
always getting shipped
Stop cooking Three fucking times when will we stop?
Okay, anyway, here we go And one time they were just balls,
but yet people still shipped them they were just balls
What do we learn?
We will never learn.
Weird.
You're so right now.
What the hell is she yapping about?
No!
I got kicked out of my sanctuary!
I talked too much!
No!
Tesla!
This is your fault!
America's only ship is to oil.
I should thank you for the same for Jen.
Thank you.
I got kicked out for talking too.
We're talking too much about shipping.
No!
Just saying too much.
I don't even remember I did this!
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
The dokey grass.
No, the dokey grass.
Oh my god.
It's not muscle memory anymore.
It's been too long since I've grasped here.
Okay.
Alright.
We just gotta...
We just gotta do this.
dokey swing okay please don't no ninja don't say that thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm sorry to tell
you this dokey the game knows tesla was right and will never
let you see please please you will never change a tesla anti
You will never change my mind!
Edison forever!
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, here you go.
It's fine.
That doesn't count as a fall.
I grasped the mountain in time.
Okay, here you go.
Alright.
We're gonna go up.
Woshi Edison for life.
Edison for life.
Mahoshi.
He can do no wrong!
Okay.
All right.
Here you go.
Grasp.
Okay.
I don't remember how to do the swing.
The Doki swing eludes me.
I spin.
My muscle memory is gone.
Okay.
Please don't!
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
as a child Edison saved me from a burning building which was
caused by Tesla's blatant for a copy of Edison's work I am
only alive due to Edison thank you oh she Edison I am 100%
see look at that we have testimonies from fellow Edison fans
look at that all right we as part of the Edison fandom we're
called the
we're we're what's our fan name guys what is the thomas
edison fan name guys what are we the eddies students the
eddie heads as as an ed as a fellow eddie head
the eddies oh the eddies i like that like that we're the
eddies guys as a fellow eddies we will not let you tarnish
our oh she's name like this fucking stupid tesla the tesla
sons i don't know i don't know i don't care enough about the
tesla fandom to know what your fan name is
oh please i can't swim anymore
I saw Edison start the fire and take care of it.
No, you did not!
That's a Tesla!
That's a Tesla.
Wait, yeah, that's my ocean.
Wait, I like that.
The light bulb is my ocean sign.
Yeah, that's what the fucking testicles say.
Yeah, that's right.
I call you testicles.
That's right, what are you gonna do about it, huh?
You don't have cool names like us, the Eddies.
That's looking right.
Trying to steal our Oshimark 2?
We all know Edison invented the light bulb.
Get your own Oshimark.
All right, here you go.
All right, no, please.
I just want to get to the sanctuary.
Oh, there you go.
We got it.
Oh, God.
What is going on with you?
Why are you freaking out on me?
Bro, Eddie's forever.
Eddie's forever.
My true fandom.
Okay.
Here you go.
I need to remember how to fucking do the swing.
The swing is so hard, guys.
It's so difficult, guys.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, I did it!
Okay.
What?
Yeah, Tesla, more like Tesla, lame.
Thank you for the chat, Richard.
Thank you.
Jesus, please.
I just want to go back.
Let me go back to the sanctuary.
Please.
Let me go back.
This game.
Please.
I have enough of FOMO.
Please, I got the FOMO.
I already have enough.
I don't want to miss.
I'm done missing out.
I'm okay with missing out now.
Okay, nice.
Okay, here you go.
All right.
Okay.
Grab.
They don't know about my light pop any stride.
Thank you for the super chat, Cass.
Thank you.
No!
Why did you f- Neapolitan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We eddies will not bow down to the testes.
That's right.
We don't even know what your fan names are.
We just call you testicles to make fun of you.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
No!
Come on just let me back in.
I just want to go back to the sanctuary All right, here you
go.
Oh, no, no, come on come on grasp grasp Okay, maybe I go up
a bit higher.
Okay here you go Nice no not dice Not nice Not nice.
Not nice.
Like I said, I can't even know as innocent as that.
Thank you for the super chat, ninja.
Thank you, thank you.
You're just brainwashed.
Don't be a sheep.
I hear you.
Okay.
Breezy, have you tried not falling?
I hear it's helpful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, I forgot.
I had my fall.
I had my fall, but I don't know.
I just turned it off, guys.
So you watch this.
Woo!
Fuck!
No!
Why do you fall like this?
Why?
Why do you fall like that?
Bro!
I just wanted to go to the city.
Okay, here you go.
Here you go.
It's okay.
I fall on purpose to perfect my technique, guys.
Like I have to perfect my technique here in the beginning
Instead of like further down the line, you know guys Like if
I perfect it here Then I won't like fuck it up next time,
you know That's you gotta perfect it in the beginning So
like you can use it later on At the later stages There you
go, see look at that Like the dokey grass I perfected it
here in the beginning And because of that Like I don't have
to worry about fucking it up at the later stages.
Oh my god.
Please.
Just let me experience.
Why did I hit my head in the sanctuary?
Why?
Why won't a shark just put me under my misery and just eat
me, please?
We're fine.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Up we go.
Imperial, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Grasp.
No, it has to be, like, perfectly here.
Grasp!
Okay, got that down.
We got the grasp down.
Okay.
Yes!
Which arm is this?
Okay, is this arm?
Okay.
Oh!
I hate this.
Oh Please oh Please
Please Please
I hate this so much I Hate this oh god Oh my god
Oh Oh, the alien's grass Okay, okay Okay Alright Alright We
made it We made it Oh, I hate that sound though I hate that
sound so much Okay
W-E-D Whoa what ISM do.
Always practice.
WWE D.
AHHHHH!
No!
I can't believe it.
We were there.
We were right there, It was actually right there.
No!
Why must you test me like this?
I've been in avid any since you've debuted.
Okay, nice.
We got it.
This is Tesla's fault.
I can feel it.
Spreading his fucking propaganda.
You'll never confirm me!
Never be a goddamn test of good
Okay, okay Hey, here you go Oh, yeah, oh god, oh god Yeah,
crap here
No, no, no, no, no There you go.
No!
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
Everything else is so easy!
Yes.
Just take me to the... I don't care.
I'm gonna settle.
I just want to go to the sanctuary.
I'm settling.
I don't care anymore.
Just take me to the sanctuary.
I don't care.
Whoa!
Please.
I'm going to settle!
Gwen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When you want to climb up, but a game detects an Edison
support tesla clothes thank you for the super chat thank you
no we're not we're gonna settle i can't i don't think we're
making it to the city okay up there you go all right at
least i trademarked the the dokey grasp there the dokey
grasp technique you're welcome okay
No!
Fuck!
God damn it, this momentum I hate it.
I'm pretty sure I'm not even doing it correctly.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's not even the correct way to fucking
do the swing.
God damn it.
Please.
That's like the hardest part.
The 360's like, why does Edison not...
doing a 360 swing how does he do it okay okay okay we need a
realiner says here we need a real liner says to be at this
edge and then ah please please please just grasp this please
oh god okay we grasp that and then And then we go from here.
Oh, this part.
I hate this part so much.
Oh, God damn it.
Let me go past this area.
We were so close.
See, that's the worst part.
We were like right there.
We're literally right there!
Oh my god.
We were literally right there.
It was so close.
We were right there.
I literally saw the sanctuary.
The sanctuary.
We were right there.
Why did I have to hit my head?
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
this is it yeah I'm gonna try this swing I'm gonna try this
huh yes oh I did it perfected a new technique that's less
that's less fucked up guys I perfected a new technique guys
no no
Please, just get me out of here.
I don't want to be here anymore.
I just want to be at the sanctuary.
Please.
Okay.
I don't understand.
Please.
Just grasping.
Alright.
Like this part.
We got down.
Hands down, the easiest part.
Okay.
This part is the easiest part for us.
But for some reason...
There we go.
For some reason we can't do the other part.
No!
I wasn't.
I didn't grab on the engine now.
I've been playing for so long.
that my background music stopped my background music was
like are you sure are you sure
you're like are you sure you'll want to keep going dokey
this is getting embarrassing now
i'm gonna settle i wanna settle that's all i want just let
me get there let me get to that one area that's all like I
don't want much just let me be in my sanctuary please if I
make it to the first checkpoint that's all I want that's all
I want no I don't care about the city anymore it's not where
Okay.
Oh god, okay.
The city is not worth it.
I realize the city was a lie.
It was a lie all along.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay.
please please oh okay we're gonna focus we're gonna focus
joki just focus just focus just keep focusing goodbye oh god
okay okay look just keep focusing just grab onto that top.
Let's grab on to the top.
Oh god.
Okay.
Just keep focusing.
Just keep focusing the promised land.
The promised land is right there.
Don't fuck up.
Yes!
We made it!
Okay, we can keep going.
No.
I'm settling.
I'm I'm gonna sit up.
I'm calling it This is my new home now.
I'm done with FOMO.
I'm done with FOMO I beat the game time FOMO is no more I've
I've made it No more FOMO for me.
No, man.
We did it.
Oh my god.
Thank you everybody for watching.
I'm sorry.
This is a short stream.
But I don't want to.
I don't want to risk losing my sanctuary.
I don't want to risk it.
Okay guys.
we hit 800,000 subscribers.
Wait, where are we at?
Alright, 700,000 subscribers.
When we hit 700,000 subscribers, I will finish the game.
I will finish the game.
700k subscribers and I will finish the game.
But for now, this Eddie has to is gonna peace out.
all right guys i literally lost super chats coming in so i'm
gonna call it here everybody but like thank you all for
coming i hope you guys enjoyed today's stream everyone it
was very chaotic as always everybody say hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you say that for me head to bed because you deserve it
i'll see you guys next time Bye guys.
Bye.